[Music]
let me give you a few situations and you
need to tell me if the change that has
occurred is physical or chemical a paper
is torn a paper is burnt water is
converted to ice V respire
which among these are physical changes
and which ones are chemical changes to
differentiate we first need to know what
physical and chemical changes mean a
physical change is a process in which
the substance experiences change in its
physical properties like shape size
appearance or state there is no change
in the internal structure or molecular
composition a chemical change on the
other hand results in the formation of
new substances entirely the actives of
one or more substances are rearranged or
combined to form a new substance now
let's get back to our examples first a
paper a stone is it a physical change or
a chemical change I'll be getting a new
substance entirely or the chemical
properties changing not at all the paper
is just torn into two pieces paper is
still paper and nothing else
hence it's a physical change what about
people being burnt here paper is
converted to ash and smoke new
substances entirely health this is a
chemical change what about water being
converted to ice here only the state of
the matter is changing which is a
physical property ice can be converted
back to water too with a little bit of
heating hence it's a physical change the
last one is interesting what happens
when we respire
we utilize the oxygen we inhale and
after the respiration process carbon
dioxide is exhaled clearly a new
substance is formed it's that chemical
change whenever a chemical change occurs
we say there's a chemical reaction
and this is what we will study in detail
what do we actually mean by it how do we
know that a reaction has taken place all
this and much more in the coming lessons
[Music]